[Music]
we're gonna be talking about revelation
revolutionising media workflows through
what we refer to as intelligent content
discovery so we'll walk you through this
and we have some demonstrations and
other exciting things but first a little
housekeeping here you have three
speakers today we have Brian Rakowski
who is a customer engineer in media for
Google Cloud we have drew Houghton who's
a machine learning specialist with
Google cloud my name is buzz Hayes I'm
the global lead of meeting entertainment
solutions for the Google cloud solutions
architecture team quickly our agenda for
today we're gonna start with an overview
of what this notion of intelligent
content is all about we'll give you a
walk through some of the steps to how
that solution is put together we'll talk
about how this applies to archives and
online or cold storage in the cloud
we'll also be talking quite a bit about
the use of AI and ml tools for media
you'll have a demo of one of our partner
tools that surfaces in a very elegant
visual fashion will surface the machine
learning data metadata that makes it
very easy to search your your content
we'll also be doing a discussion about
how discovery our pals at discovery
thank you for being here are using
intelligent content in their monstrous
archive and awesome archive I should say
and will also tell you how to get
started on this whole process for those
of you who have the next app if you go
to this particular session you'll find a
link for a Dory so if you have any
questions feel free to enter it there we
also have microphones here so feel free
at the end we'll have some time for Q&A
to step up to the mic and ask the
questions
so without further ado let's take a look
at what intelligent content is all about
so we're gonna take the sort of a top
view here of the process it starts with
consolidating the media you've got media
in all sorts of places and in sorts of
all sorts of forms so you really want to
bring that all into a single platform or
at least a similar platform it may be
cloud but it may be mul
to cloud in this case but you want to
put all your assets together then you
want to apply machine learning tools and
we have a lot of automated tools now
that are not only easy to use but
they're also easy to modify which is
great and drew we'll get into some of
that in a little bit but this allows you
to gain new insights and apply metadata
to both your audio and visual data that
includes documents and photographs as
well and then once your content has
intelligence you basically you have the
the power of your entire archive of your
fingertips a lot of archives right now
don't exist in any meaningful
meaningfully searchable form and we'll
get into why that is in a minute but
ultimately you want to be able to find
everything that's in there and leverage
that for whatever purpose so the vast
majority of media archives especially at
the Hollywood studios and television
entities exists in a form that can't
even be viewed let alone monetized so we
have some solutions to help figure that
out as well and then once the library is
made meaningfully searchable by adding
the metadata using the machine learning
and AI tools you can begin to broaden
your use of these tools to gain further
insights and derive analytics from that
content which can be very important and
so it increases the level of insight you
have into this content pretty
dramatically so let's go a little bit
deeper into this here's how it works
you're basically starting by ingesting
the content into GCS into cloud storage
and that storage can cut the the content
can come from variety places whether
it's already on some spinning disk
someplace on a server some physical
storage like tape for example a data
tape it could also be video tape it
could be film other things but they have
to be digitized obviously so once all of
those assets are available you ingest
those import those into cloud storage
and then using a variety of the the GCP
tools we can then apply all of the
various relevant tools to derive these
insights so whether you're trying to
derive visual information from images
you're trying to drive speech from audio
you're trying to arrive derive text from
images variety of things can be
leveraged and mostly automatically
which is great and then you can start to
visualize that data through various ways
and you'll have a demo again in a few
minutes of one of the partner solutions
we have for visualizing that data how
many of you use media asset management
software at this point yeah how many of
you absolutely love the tool you have
wait I don't see any hands something's
wrong okay
it was once asked to me by a studio
client why media asset management can't
be as simple as a Google search and the
beauty of the intelligent content
discovery is that it can be as simple as
a Google search you want to be able to
ask questions the way the humans who are
looking for the answers are asking them
that scene with a woman in the blue
dress and she said good morning she had
a hat you know that kind of thing you
want to be able to surface meaningful
data from even obtuse queries like that
and then once you have that you can
activate this content in a variety of
different ways and I think there are
many goldmines sitting out there that
are yet to be explored just because they
don't have meaningful metadata attached
to them so there are a number of
different formats out there and
apologies to any of you who are diehard
supporters of any of these formats and
I'm about to to dis here a little bit
but it's difficult to find insights in
your content if it's sitting on some
physical media that hasn't been brought
into a platform like cloud to be able to
analyze it so you're still talking about
a lot of LTO tape or some form of data
tape and has men even know a tape in it
itself is not inherently archival I
guess it depends on your definition of
archival you can talk to LTO
manufacturers they'll probably tell you
that the table last 35 years which is
true if you don't use it and then if you
start to use it you start getting wear
and tear that shelf life ends up getting
much much smaller so you really rely on
the physical storage and luckily you
know we have great partners like Iron
Mountain who do a very good job of
climate control and things for physical
asset media but it really requires
diligence to make sure that that data is
still good and you have to check it also
with LTO you tend to have to migrate it
to whatever the newest format is because
most of these LTO formats are not
backward-compatible more
than maybe a version so you end up with
significant physical damage
possibilities bit rot for example if
it's hasn't been checked in a while so
there's a number of reasons why LTO is
becoming a bit more problematic
especially given the volume of content
that we have now it's almost too much
major studios will migrate their entire
collections to new - LTL formats every
few years and it's becoming
prohibitively expensive to do that the
manual tagging of assets you know a lot
of people have been applying metadata
the terms been around forever and
they've been using human resources to do
that which is great it's a bit
error-prone because if you have 50
humans they're gonna be interpreting
things differently they're not all going
to give the same results on things plus
it's a little bit error-prone and you're
basically having to watch things
transcribe things and really it requires
a lot of paying attention and there's so
much content that it's almost impossible
for human beings to do all this
transcription so that's another reason
why using something like intelligent
content discovery makes a lot of sense
you also find in this day and age if
you're working especially in feature
films you have day and date releases of
films that have to go out in multiple
formats to dozens of countries talking
with an executive at Disney and one of
the latest Marvel releases went out in
over a hundred versions on the same day
so there's a lot of content that has to
be taken care of and some of that
content is it has to be filtered because
there are certain regional requirements
you know their censorship boards in
various parts of the country they have
very strict rules there's often
inappropriate content for various
audiences there's other things that has
to be trapped before it goes out there
so compliance is a big issue and so
using the ML tools to automatically
derive that those insights can be very
helpful especially when you have these
massive volumes of content and again to
find that traditionally the
inappropriate content required a person
having to sit there and find it so what
if you knew what your content knows so
the idea is if you're consistently
applying the same tools and the same
metadata you're surfacing the same
metadata for your entire library you're
gonna have to find consistency is
actually a great benefit you'll see in
this demo in a few minutes that
you can now surface things that are like
something you found so if you found
something you really like by having
consistent metadata you can also surface
other things just like that which can be
very very useful when you're trying to
leverage the assets in your media
library so it makes the entire library
the life of that library considerably
longer if you find that you can use
these insights to leverage licensing a
lot of Studios now are finding that they
have great revenue in stock footage
footage this not used in the film but
they shot it for the film it's not
unusual for a film to have a very high
shooting ratio these days because of
digital technology used to be when we
shot film we'd shoot a ten to one ratio
for every minute of screen time there'd
be 10 minutes of capture nowadays it's
not unusual to have two or three hundred
to one so there's a lot of content that
never makes it into the movie so why not
monetize that but you have to know where
it is first so obviously we want to be
able to reduce the time it takes to do
this you need to prepare the content for
your distribution so we can apply these
tools again to find sensitive content to
derive closed captioning for example a
number of things we want to optimize the
content and adhere to whatever
compliance process there is every
country has different restrictions on
that and again we want to create rich
and consistent metadata that's the key
so as the value that comes with
intelligent media content is to really
understand how to make meaningfully
searchable metadata it's easy to surface
metadata that's that's not very useful
we want to make sure that it is useful
and we provide labels as part of that to
identify certain objects in the frame
and then we can then search our content
very quickly and cost-effectively we
could also provide intelligent search
capabilities for media archives and
enable consumers to find their content
very quickly and easily and that's
important especially this day and age
with deadlines being what they are you
also reduced fines and risks of which
there are very real when it comes to
inappropriate content and you can find
new ways to monetize this content
through the information that's derived
so let's take a quick look here at the
steps on our way to the solution as you
can see here you basically you identify
the right partner to get the data out of
your data or your physical library and
that
in many cases some of the tools that we
have you can do that yourself or you can
partner with one of our partner
companies to do that you ingest your
archives into GCP we have partners that
specialize in that as well we have
partners that help you migrate your tape
libraries your data tape libraries we
have other partners that will help you
take your physical assets like videotape
and film and migrate those into the
platform and then you can generate the
insights from our Google Cloud ml tools
in a variety of ways which we'll talk
about a little bit and then once you've
got that you can organize it make it all
accessible which is really quite simple
again because of the consistency aspect
to the metadata and then you really get
some meaningful insights into these
tools and that's the important thing
about most archives because we haven't
had the luxury of that in a while so
here's some of the media partners that
we have and this is by no means an
exhaustive list but from connectivity to
data migration to the ml and AI tools to
the actual content management and the
list is growing every day and all of
these are vital components to the
ecosystem of the intelligent content
discovery process so very quickly by
moving your media assets into the cloud
you'll have unprecedented control over
that content however there's many
different types of media archives and
most of them are not digital according
to the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences half of the films made
prior to 1950 no longer exist in any
form and that's just because of neglect
and the fact that it wasn't really
considered something people needed to
hold on to until it was too late so
we're trying to curb that and videotape
is even worse and I think we're about to
realize that in a few years when we
start to go back to these older archives
and realize we can't read the data
anymore so this analog content is really
important to us so we've been working
with media archives all over the world
to help come up with solutions to get
all of the content digitized and make it
intelligently searchable so that then it
could be brought to market if that's the
intention or preserved which is another
intention of a lot of older material but
at least be able to make this this
content more stable and searchable and
then by applying media search we can do
really cool things like just entering a
line of dialogue or the name of an actor
or an actress or even their character
name or what
wearing in a scene or the location where
they are and be able to surface very
quickly the the visual content that
relates to those searches that are asked
in human terms not in boolean search
terms for example so if you're using the
power of Google Cloud you can definitely
find what your you and your audience was
looking for by applying this data so
with this huge variety of both digital
and physical assets we need more and
more efficient solutions to be able to
migrate this to cloud and that's that's
sort of key and all of this is getting
stuff in there quickly here's some
quickly some overviews of storage
solutions because we have a variety of
different use cases here and so we have
streaming video we have video
transcoding backup archival and disaster
recovery to mention just a few and we
have different storage classes for all
those as you're probably all aware we
also yesterday announced a new cold line
storage tier which is arguably less
expensive than tape which is which is
great this is for data that's acts less
far less than what you would normally
use for regional storage so it's
important to note that you have
different levels of storage for all of
the different media needs you have so
it's important through all of this that
when you're trying to derive the
insights from this metadata that it's
put into a useful form where you can
actually read it and make sense of it
and I think it's really important to
know that there are tools out there that
currently do this for you I don't know
if any of you have seen the output of a
just an ml process but typically it's
just a gigantic JSON file with a ton of
text and numbers and brackets in it and
it's not the most friendly thing to work
with so to show a little bit more about
how these insights can be leveraged I
want to introduce drew Houghton who's
going to walk you through the machine
learning and AI aspects of the
intelligent content discovery true
awesome Thank You buzz so let's talk a
little bit more about the capabilities
we can implement on our content once
it's in the cloud once we have it in a
more usable accessible format so within
Google Cloud we provided a variety of
different ways to use machine learning
from off-the-shelf api's all the way to
the latest and greatest and machine
learning researcher and data science
tools we're gonna focus mainly on the
off-the-shelf API is the models that
Google builds and maintains using Google
size data sets and Google size and
google expertise in particular for media
the media archives that we're talking
about our vision API and our video API
are critical first steps to tagging your
data
we'll talk about a lot of the different
things that you can get out of these
api's it's worth noting that you can
call these api's with a single restful
call you don't need to have a tremendous
amount of compute in google cloud or a
tremendous amount of ml expertise it's
very easy to add these into existing
applications so these api's will I'll
talk about some of the methods but
detect a lot of predefined labels and
the models that we build but you'll
notice up here we have Auto ml vision
auto mail video which we just announced
this these are really powerful
capabilities that allow you to define
what you're looking for in your content
you need to provide some training data
and Wilson will show you a really easy
way to do that but then you can run
these Auto ml API is on your data and
get the tags and the information that
you care about not the tags that that's
part of just the Google taxonomy right
that's something we hear a lot from
customers is the off-the-shelf
API is that they see across Google and
other providers are nice but they have
really specific things or looking to
detect and they have on-the-ground
expertise will producers etc who are
looking for very specific things but
aren't ml experts or maybe even
developers and so we'll show how we can
iterate that here are a lot of different
things you can do with it the API is
it's not just limited to vision or video
right there's all the standard metadata
tagging we get with our video and vision
api's were doing things like logo
detection landmark detection will
actually tell you latitude and longitude
if we recognize a landmark will
recognize faces and sentiments and this
is sort of the backbone of your your
smart media archive is just all the tags
you get what is on the in the frame on
the screen we can also use feature to
texts so this is transcription if
there's audio if you have an audio file
or there's audio in your video will
output
in a highly accurate manner what is
being said if there's multiple speakers
not an issue we can handle that as well
we do translation so this is as part of
that localization challenge right how do
we how do we create translated
transcriptions of what's going on how do
we make our content searchable in
multiple languages even if we're not
doing a closed captioning using this it
would be great to know what's being said
in a video across many languages to then
make it searchable and discoverable by
our users and if you have a relatively
small data set of labelled data and you
want to improve the API you can do that
using auto mail translate you would
provide the you'd provide us your your
level data either a dictionary of words
a word or sentence to sentence and with
a clickable button will trainee even
more accurate translation API just for
your usage because it's using your data
to improve it we can do sentiment
extraction using the natural language
API so is is this a generally positive
clip or a generally negative clip among
other things we can classify very
quickly what is what is in the clip like
I said one of the things that video
intelligence API will also do is shot
detection so it helps you to break up
your video and then discover what is in
these different shots so you can either
quickly find and create content
shot-for-shot or in some cases I've
worked with with customers actually
generate content on the fly using
techniques like the the shot detection
so let's let's dive a little bit deeper
into the video intelligence API and the
the auto mobile video API and talk about
the methods we have so with a single API
you can tell us to run one or all of
these ml passes on your data so there's
the label detection and that's what are
we seen what are the actions that are
happening what's on screen will do text
detection or OCR so if there's any text
on screen you'll get that and that's
really valuable from a search standpoint
logo detection really important if
you're looking for content for to build
a partnership or understand how often a
partner is on screen will do speech
transcriptions so even though even
though you're sending in you're setting
the video so it's audio and video will
do
transcription is part of that single API
call which makes that a lot easier for
you to implement explicit content
detection is critical so understanding
what what is on screen when it might be
more sensitive in particular for
localization different markets care
about different aspects of explicit
content detection whether it's violence
adult content etc and we mentioned a
shot change detection all of this can be
done with a single API call huge amount
of information you get back on your
content so some new announcements with
the video intelligence API in particular
we used to just offer batch mode which
was you had a PETA video file on Google
Cloud storage you would call the API and
point the API at that file we now
support file streaming so let's say you
have a large a large file you can create
a gif PC streaming connection and send
that basically byte for byte up to the
API you don't need to land that in GCS
obviously a lot of workflows and the
workflow we're talking about recommends
that you have the content on GCS but
let's say you have either a real time
situation or a use case where the files
elsewhere and you don't want to move it
right we support that now and I
mentioned real time we now support live
streaming so we support HLS RTSP and
rtmp great for understanding live
content what's being said what's on
screen a super helpful if you're doing
custom ad placement just-in-time ad
placement and in the prefetch for
example on the online content you can
know in real time what's on screen and
do quite a lot with that so we're gonna
show you a demo using one of our several
partners on the ml video intelligence
end so this is we're gonna be using 0 of
video Intelligence Platform Zvi so Zvi
is is as you'll see in a second it's
really intuitive front-end GUI it's the
back end document model and also applies
some custom ml and clustering ml as well
it's a really easy way to use all these
api's in an accessible manner no coding
required and you'll see just how
powerful the combination of these two
technologies are so behind the scenes
how the solution is going to work
first you'd import the assets into
cloud then index them there's a clip of
fine process where we create proxies so
you might have a two-hour file but we'll
create three five-second clips of that
content just proxies oh so we're not
transcoding we're not creating an
additional burden there then we can
either use the Google ml api's API is
off the shelf or train our own models
and will actually show you both we'll
run all those ml passes over the content
and then you'll have these search
capability across your entire archive so
here's the architecture you just saw
this is again in this case we're using 0
as the front 10 but we've seen we have a
number different partners we've seen
people build some similar solutions
themselves and this is the order
important assets creating the proxies
and indexing training models running the
models and then ultimately you get a
very intelligent archive that you can
then use to find content to build that
into your production workflow there's
quite a lot you can do with this so
actually all right so here we are in the
zero interface we have gone ahead and I
need a refresh so we have already run
the khalipa fication process the and all
the ml passes across our data so we have
a data set in this case we didn't
actually maybe this is a data set that
you don't really know what's in there
this is one of the powerful things we
find out is you might have a ton of data
and not even understand what's in your
archive we've seen this again time and
again with customers so each clip we've
run the ml passes on so we can see here
if I select this clip metadata on the
Left we have all sorts of creative
analysis we have all the different tags
we pulled from the API so we've actually
detected some faces and pulled some
values of the sentiment we see here are
all the different tags that we pulled
out at the API and as was mentioned you
get quite a lot of data out of these
api's so one of the powerful things of a
solution like this is we're not throwing
away tags we're just putting it in a
database and making it searchable so
you're not having to look at this clip
and look at all 50 tags but when you
search for it it does get a hit and it's
there and we've run in this environment
we've run the video API the vision
API speech-to-text we've done natural
language we've done sentiment detection
and we will show you auto ml so we've
run all these api's already on this
content so now I can do things like
Google style search I could search for
house right and I get different clips of
people's houses inside outside also some
flips of the white house if I search
white house that'll kind of zero in to a
more specific search if I do white house
and portrait you can see how quickly I
found that specific clip I was looking
for right this is very natural this is
how we search and by the way the search
is going across the tags it's going
across the speech-to-text it combines
all this different data into a very
intuitive interface so for example I can
search if I search mother I remember
that there was some you know that we
shot a lot of we'd a lot of capture
there was a particularly wanted in this
very long interview if I run this clip
we'll actually find out and I'm a
quilter and I'm a mother so what you
kind of heard what what was said within
the metadata we actually have a
transcription of what was said in this
clip so now I can combine text searches
with tag searches with some of the other
capabilities that 0 gives you so one one
slick feature that you get as part of
the zero front end is a clustering sort
of image similarity or shot similarity
search so I can see here maybe I have a
shot that's like this and I kind of like
you to the color or I like that scene I
want to find other shots that are
similar that's not a good one
we'll take this one and with that image
similarity search I find all of the
other clips that are similar from a
clustering standpoint there's some some
unstructured machine learning going on
here what's cool with this is the the
kind of we'll talk about well we can do
that in a second we can see here we've
actually created some smart searches
using these tags so we have lots and
lots of tags in the backend now with
this interface that's really easy to
decide tags we care about build a smart
search and then
do things like hey I've want to find all
the different angry clips or someone's
angry maybe combine that with an actor's
name so I want all the angry clips of
actor a B or C and kind of I can create
these smart searches if I know what I'm
looking for ahead of time if I'm not I
just type into the search bar the the
way I've been showing we do OCR so if
there's text on-screen that becomes
searchable as well and the last thing
I'll show you which i think is very
slick is our auto ml integration so you
can upload your content into Auto ml
train a model do that all in the Google
Cloud console we have several partners
including this that will actually
integrate with our the API so you don't
even have to go into Google cloud
yourself to do this so for example we've
built up a small training set you can
see have 13 videos 13 12 11 of different
shop types so this is something that the
API was not returning it wasn't saying
this is a closed up this is a medium
closed this is a full full or long shot
but this is a tag that I really care
about as an end user right this is from
a production workflow standpoint I
really want to know what were the shop
types and maybe we have a different
definition than someone else might so
with just a small amount of data here
you can see the different shot types
that have classified closed up full
medium shot right we have built in Auto
a male model and it's pretty easy to do
you right click and click train with
Auto Mel video or vision vision would
take thumbnails build a training set and
now you have a custom model video we'll
look at the entire clip and build a
model based on that we can see here that
just from these 13 videos in each
category when the model got trained it
was then applied to the entire archive
and we can see here I've identified all
the close-up shots and my archive using
just 13 examples I've identified all the
full shots and my archive using just
those few examples and I can actually
kind of tune the sensitivity if I want
to make it even more certain that it's a
full shot not only that I can improve
the model over time so one of the things
I can do is if I identify something that
I don't think is a full shot
let's see if I can find one maybe yeah
maybe I say this is this isn't a fool
this is maybe medium what I can do is
take this clip I can add it to all right
you very easily add it into the folders
into that training set right live demos
right and then you have the new data hit
training with Google automail vision
without going into Google Cloud console
right this data is going to be uploaded
you have a train set 20 minutes later
that new model gets applied across all
of your archive so very easy to consume
ml even for your producers whoever is
interacting with this content alright so
with that I'm head off to Brian Rakowski
to walk you through the next section so
my name is Brian Rakowski I'm a Google
cloud customer engineer and I've been
working with discovery for a little
while now and it's really my privilege
to be up here today because the work
we've been doing with discovery is
really actually transforming their
content into intelligent content so this
is real live production stuff here
against thousands of hours of content so
I'm excited to talk to you about it
today but before I begin can I see a
show of hands of how many people have
used our ml api's before a few of you
alright alright well hopefully after
this you'll all go out and try it but
for those of you that haven't used it
before like buzz alluded to whenever you
run an MLA API this is what's returned a
lot of JSON and you can imagine if
you've got thousands upon thousands of
hours of content just imagine how much
JSON you'll get back what do you do with
that JSON how do you get value from it
how do you normalize it how do you store
it where do you store it right but
probably more importantly how do you
actually visualize it how do you you
know gain
value from that machine learning how do
you make your processes more efficient
how do you make your workforce more
efficient it to save time right so let's
talk about how discovery is doing this
today first they have a partner named
SDI one of our Google cloud technology
partners and SP VI has been in this
business for some time now they work
with large media companies like
Discovery Fox sky and Turner as well as
others and what they do is they focus on
the media supply chain they they are
able to manage and optimize the
technical applications in order to
process content they abstract that
infrastructure that's needed to do all
of this and one example is they can
actually automate the process of running
all the content through our ml AP is so
the way that SDI describes themselves as
they're like a factory right you're a
large media company you're getting
content in from producers or other
sources you've got to do a dozen
multiple dozens of things to that
content before it's ready for
distribution and scpi really helps
automate that entire workflow for you
the other key thing is how do you
actually again make this valuable to
your workforce how do you you know
really enhance their abilities to do
their work and scpi has a program called
rally access which is a plugin for Adobe
Premiere so this is what discovery
actually utilizes to visualize all of
that ml beta and their editing suite and
what this allows them to do is things
like compliance and distribution
versioning metadata tagging caption
validation among many other things so
let's talk about what discovery is doing
today discovery is utilizing our video
intelligence API to do labeling explicit
content detection speech to text
transcription and all of those things
are allowing them to allow their editors
who search for labels right in Adobe
Premiere it allows them to find words
that people said you can search through
that content and find where somebody
said something in a piece of content
and in doing this it's really making
them more efficient they can go in edit
a video send it up to the cloud for
rendering and save a lot of time in that
process and what it's doing for
discovery is enhancing their QC process
it can take one hour or for one out
content hour it can take up to two hours
normally to do a QC this is helping them
cut that down to sometimes fifteen
minutes so that's a huge savings right
but then layer upon that how many
thousands upon thousands of hours of
content come into somebody like
Discovery every year and you can
immediately see the massive savings that
machine learning can provide a company
so at a high level this is what we've
helped discovery build do the help of
SDI and discovery you can see on the
left there they are ingesting content
from multiple data sources it gets
ingested into Google cloud and store it
on our object storage and then they can
run a trance code on that to create the
proxy file which is what's going to be
used to run the ml api's against so you
take that proxy file and run it against
each of the api's and get all that json
data back and then you store it in the
SUV i rally database and that's where
they normalize the data and make sure
it's in a format that's ready to be
consumed by an end user and then on the
far right you can see how somebody on
Prem or anywhere could go into Adobe
premier see their task orders their work
orders and actually start to edit that
content in adobe premier pulling that
Mme metadata out of the cloud so I'm
gonna show you a video of how this looks
in SDB is a trial the access panel so
you select your task order you can go in
and then select the labels with a time
based metadata showing up on the left
you'll see that there's actually time
based metadata for each label with ins
and outs for that particular label so
you see they can select one and it shows
right on the editing panel where that
video is so if you need to find say sum
or search for some explicit content for
example that would take you right to
that point in video so you're not
spending time looking through that
entire
trying to find specific things that need
to be QC so you can also see in the
middle there they have the time codes
right in the sequence so you can go in
and see exactly as you're scanning
through that file what the labels are
during that sequence so this is what
Discovery's utilizing today with the
help of s DVI and our machine learning
technology now I want to talk to you a
little bit you know how can you get
started doing this yourself
and there's really three ways one is
talk to your account team you know
somebody like me a Google customer
engineer and we can help guide you
through this give you demos get you in
touch with partners on how to build this
yourselves you can talk to the partners
themselves they can show you what their
technology can do and help you and then
you can engage with our professional
services organization and they're the
ones that will actually come in and help
build this with you actually deploy it
in your environments
[Music]